there's two things one I apologize for
the hairdo I just got done doing a video
game confession uh - barracks a
bad guy no no calm it that's like my
favorite character we're watching this
and this is the sting anything yeah no
yeah we're watching I'm just like well
it the bad guy the one that steals all
the robots and stuff I'm like this can't
be a tar-like 2.0 because I'm like no
that's too obvious has to be someone
else I was thinking like would it be
cool if it was the father like one day
I'd be just the biggest wizard
everything I'm just like you know what I
think it's good I was like it could be
Varrick cuz I'm like he would want Asami
to be working with him you know he would
want and then you were just like no I
don't know that it's like it'd be much
cooler if it was the father and I was
like I I hate to sound no yeah then
they're showing the the robot detonators
is up like no no what I I remember
telling you I was like I hate to sound
like this but considering the way the
seasons been running so far I'm not sure
the show was smart enough to have it be
as twisty as the father why Vera qua
love them
the artist formerly known as Howard
Hughes and that make it more how would
you with the sir the flesh Gordon and
the Nanook of the north combination and
it's great it's of the north and oh yeah
the south yeah this are combined like
the Batman serials doing stop talk hero
of the song that was so that was my
favorite part of the episode yeah oh and
you know maybe maybe he's not maybe he's
not in on it maybe maybe Julie is the
mastermind like going behind his back
and stealing this stuff would that be a
twist like a twist on top of it - its
but they're probably not gonna - it
could be but it'd be so great
no you gotta be totally justified though
he's been really funny so far so can you
imagine him as a villain I know I guess
that's why it's such a good well that's
waste you know but I don't know wasn't
that much of a twist I was actually no I
know I mean it's like it makes yours I
thought was the much better twist like
this whole time it was Cora's father and
well it's wow that would be twisted
heartbreaking and good idea
they're never gonna do it but no it's
not like hey it's too obvious uh not not
that's too obvious it's just that I
liked the character too much I don't
want him to be a bad guy he's too funny
it's a good guy um so I love it by the
way I love the scene where Baco comes
and he's like don't worry I know who it
is
and he like just looks at it means like
and I'm really close
yeah well talk to you later Asami I'm
like subtle it like what Roger but yeah
it might didn't be like hey I know it's
you if I ever come in in the middle of a
conversation somebody's like you know
who did I'm like I know and I'll get to
the bottom of it just assume I know it's
you okay I'm sure so cuz I know we
constantly plot against each other but
okay I like aside from now let's talking
about the rest of the episode um well
actually again we got to talk about the
ending because the biggest part was the
second end okay so interesting question
did you miss core head much I honestly
no halfway through it I miss like well I
haven't seen any core and I'm like I'm
kind of okay do I miss her look this is
really sad but I was like not really in
the rest of the episode even though it's
kind of fillory is interesting enough
without I was enjoying ever thought I'd
say that but but not I will say this the
angle that they're taking now don't
botch it up I guess because I want a few
people possibly that actually likes MD
show stories I like that so one has to
relearn stuff and looking at themselves
from a totally different point of view
I find them insufferable unless handled
right that's right they had any handled
right they come not a handled right I'm
not against this idea entirely but I'm
like oh tread carefully kiss oh I feel
botched up more times I see it done well
but I think if done right it can be done
so well so my only argument is I just
figured she amnesia already because it
seems like whatever a gala never season
yeah I'm like it's almost like the first
season didn't happen at all and she
wakes up and she's like whose car and
there's a part of me and I'm just like
really so we're gonna do this twice now
because we've just done it already
yeah with a bear if it just started off
yeah with her wig it just you know
what's going on oh okay I better learn
all my lessons again it's like yeah it's
as heck but another part of me is just
like great if we start from Ground Zero
now maybe we haven't right I'm so
missing Guinea um well and then you had
an interesting thought about would it be
cool if the show actually opened up with
her having it yeah like this is a flange
when it cut to the scene and she wakes
up in like who's Cora I I seriously was
just like oh they did this all backwards
why didn't they just open up this entire
season with that one scene open it up on
the beach with the Fire Nation guys
we're here to help you avatar who's the
avatar I would have been hot hot back
yeah and then and then literally like
how did you get here and she'd be like I
don't remember and then make the recipe
a flash bag it would have given it would
have made so much more sense I would
have been with her more yeah because it
would have been like okay this is what
drove her to this point and I normally
I'm not a huge like oh it has to be done
like a Christopher Nolan film where it's
backwards and out of order and a lot of
times if it helps yeah a lot of times
it's a cheap gimmick but in this case I
think it really would have saved this
season a lot because you would have been
like okay how did we get to this point
and then you can see the crazy decisions
she made and you're just like okay so
that's how she ended up on a beach in
the middle of an island and the but that
I mean how do we like blame the show for
that that's just more hate one it than
cool you know if they did that I think
it would have been a lot better because
I the linear storytelling this time
around because we went through season
one in season two I mean this has been
the biggest gripe we've had it's kind of
like I don't feel like we've progressed
anywhere well we might actually be I'm
like okay well now you can start from
ground again I mean I think with even
the fill er up fill er episodes in
and even Cory season one you kind of
accepted because again you know what the
big focus is you know what the big
driving force is and sometimes you know
you need a break in your filler episode
and here again me because the focus is
not as or at least what they're fighting
for is not as strong or not as focused
uh the filler episodes are becoming a
little bit more noticeable but I will
say they're still fun this was still fun
and it does do a trick I love which is
it's the trick silent slams did where I
remember Jonathan Demme I used to talk
about how like yeah we lose all our
principal characters for fifteen minutes
of film that happens very rarely you are
yeah I like it when Hannibal escapes you
lose Hannibal you lose Clarice Starling
and you're stuck with a bunch of side
characters and if done right it's
actually really cool and I think this
really did it right well the town side
is that you're kind of glad to be gone
the character that's what I guess to me
it did I I run the problem with the show
like corn maque oh how much more
interesting is ma Co now yeah my bonus
Tommy over bath left cuz I'm like oh so
now those two are at it against him like
wait a second we're just doing a love
triangle old Oh God yeah that's right
then she kisses Evans like oh come on
and then Eddie broke up with her with
honestly I think Marco should just stay
with the semi I usually one would say
five minutes in this episode they shared
together was more interesting than
anything that's gone on with either and
Marco so far well you didn't like seeing
korimako argue over and over her beat
him being totally legit and
understanding her just being a wacky
little bitch
I can't talk about way about her but she
is this season cuz she hasn't learned
and it's not fun
but but maybe they'll make this fun now
with the amnesia they may be like trying
to regain her senses you'll realize like
I wonder if this was their attempt at a
reboot just like you know what was
season one it was good but we wrote
ourselves into a corner now if we give
ramneyg we just start over from the
beginning total reboot I like it which
I'm sorry with you I am I'm both really
afraid of the amnesia but I'm also
cautiously optimistic because I think so
much can be done with it uh and I like
it when it's done anybody's all really
seen it done right um so I will ask this
too with all the constant has the city
just gone insane with like oh there's
going to the gangsters and stuff like
that like okay this is still someone
trying to be for kids right cuz that was
just like you know kids if stuff gets
too hard or difficult in the world's not
your side uh yes yes start a war go to
the Mafia I'm like and the whole world
is with it like I don't I don't get it
no I have a problem with I mean we've
already talked about korra took stupid
pills along the way and she's in her own
little world but it's amazing how they
wrote such strong interesting characters
in the first season and now we've got
the opposite the strong interesting
characters have become sidelined or just
gotten dumb while the ones that we kind
of had is she's like maka was the one
lassies I was like this is the weakest
and now he's and I was like the more
sensible um you know but what a great
character when beifong was and what have
they done to her did she take stupid
pills so I got a smart out you berate
cop will only save the world my gosh I'm
about to beat cop get the out and
what what and these two very obviously
like crooked kind of you know yeah
like star okay Joe Guidice ya
know they're like the Bella grow with us
they're like the Ace Ventura cops the
ones are just like oh but you can do mr.
video this is Simpsons like you you
watch too many detective movie set
take him away toy did you say chief
commander was a kid says like I'm like
Lin beifong was such a great character
just watching her be stupid yeah this
season is just like I'm just scratching
my head like is this the same person
from season one who only got outwitted
it seemed to me when like really like
Amon was pretty smart and like was
seriously 12 steps ahead but like these
two idiot goofs she's got working for
and I'm like you get alright you out and
it seems like all the agretti aggressive
characters all the characters they're
like going forward and like going behind
people's backs and stuff like that it's
like they know viewers you know and very
much Joker's like seeing that stuff but
there has to be something you've got
identify with them there has to be an
intelligence to it there's no
intelligence to the aggression in this
show that's what really shocks me oh no
good at it I ever see somebody with
somebody was saying in the comments that
I came off as like chauvinistic I'm like
I know to me it's the opposite I think
all the female characters have just like
this with the exception of Asami but
Ella sobbing is being tricked by verax
so I mean but it just seems like they've
had I don't know like they've sucked out
the intelligence and like particularly
Lin beifong and Cora are just like and
they were so strong now it the only I
mean the only characters that are like
hey they still have this sort of like
this honestly this intelligence is
Mako's now like you say he's really
sensible now and all that okay the tents
and side stories that don't seem to have
much to do with anything
at least he's staking out the busy
started up to actually I missed I missed
enema can I see them trained believers
someone
yeah just that's a bad sign when that's
more interesting than your main your
main plot is try to get a bad sign when
the side plots are mori cuz I was like I
was actually kind of with this episode
I'm like alright what's going on I was
like let's see ma ko investigate this
stupid short film they do God asked
that was priceless uh you know but uh
Bolin yeah Bolin's always been stupid so
Vance you know it's fun sing and be
stupid and Kenny's ego fed um yeah I've
given up on the whole Bolin Sami thing
like I thought well that might be
interesting they're like now they're
just gonna be going out our back with
maka again missus I'd be fine with that
if they my only things like that why
didn't you just do that in the first
place but I you know I don't know I'll
tell you this though if he gets together
with Asami again and then breaks up with
her again to go back to Korra I'm
walking this is kind of out because I'm
like that's yeah I still want to see one
of the lemurs and the fire ferret get
together and then they have a love
triangle with the flying Buffalo because
that would be interesting and then you'd
have a fluffle oh yes it'd be much more
interesting than a the love triangle
they're still trying to pull uh
so I okay so a me what's people probably
think like we've really hate this show
now and i don't know actually i thought
this was better than the last ones
yeah i guess but it's an interesting
hook i wish i had done it at the
beginning of the season but yeah okay
that's a cool book no my thought on the
season so far and again could all come
together i don't know but um is that
it's it's still interesting and but it
seems much more interested in the side
stories and the side characters than it
does its main character and its main
story and i don't think that's a good
thing oh good bye but I like the side
story and I like the side characters but
I wish it was more focused on the main
the key word being main story and main
character I'll tell you what my problem
is the first season I thought overall
and you can go on and on but who
preferred to do but even with
pro-bending as a way to instruct Korra
how to do team work and to introduce
Malcolm Bolin the first season I thought
was really tightly written we've got a
clear villain we have a political
movement we have it was just it was very
tight like they crammed a lot in there
and it worked this one sorry first yeah
I feel like it's like we're six
in and it's just everywhere we've got
Desna and the other twin we've got
analog we've got Varrick now tensions
are ease you know what I feel like it's
the difference between watching like The
Dark Knight versus The Dark Knight Rises
or it's like the Dark Knight's the
really tight story and it's and it's
pretty well put together despite an
issue or two and O's it's dark my life
dark yeah and the Dark Knight Rises is
just like everywhere and all over the
map and it's like yeah it's alright but
it's kind of like it's like I feel like
there's just been a lot of just taking
their damn time like when I'm like you
you did everything so quickly like in
the first season that to just kind of
just like take your time and all of
these little side stories that aren't
quite adding up like the varix netted
the the the whole ship thing and this
one was cool but again it's almost like
the war in the last episode where it's
like we've been promised something and
then nothing's delivered on my wall okay
so bear it's a bad guy that's cool but
we just wasted an entire episode on a
boat to get there I mean I get it's it's
cool I mean the the seasons still cool
but it's like yeah it's like I'm missing
the meat of it you know but the main
stuff like I said the main storm she
gets swallowed by a giant spirit Shh I'm
gonna be slight than him spin around I
guess I don't know um yeah I thought we
were gonna get more of like the spirit
you know and again I I'm totally fine if
they take a break from her I mean even
if I like to the character right now I
still be okay if they took a break
because I'm with you I like it when they
take a break from the main care I'm over
guess on the side characters but it does
very clearly show of the main problems
is that we would so much rather watch
these side characters do practically
nothing than our people character you
had a great line when unalaq shows up at
the the South Pole spirit tree whatever
with the bright light the second he
shows up it was like oh yeah a spirit
world so let's call so your mood a lot
of you know lot yeah oh yeah like you
know like I'm like that's right we
haven't even seen our main villain like
do
anything I think we had one battle plan
where he's like we should do this no my
brother will be kept busy for a while
now cut to another see ya
so what you get is is fine if it still
either really kept the focus either
either the focus of the story the main
story has to be in check or the main
character has to be in check oh my god
can't believe I'm referencing this in
the news show Sleepy Hollow which is
surprisingly entertaining as Apple I got
you hooked it's like one of the most fun
shows you'll see oh yeah it is to finish
it itself no I swear to God he didn't
believe me and I wouldn't believed it
either but it's actually good but
the the Headless Horseman has
disappeared for like three episodes you
know but the you know a notice so that's
the maker the main focus right the may
but their age still talking about the
main focus and B you still have your
main characters and they're in telling a
plot yeah there's no one of they hear
more and more well here I mean it's like
I said we'll have a tent inside story or
a mock go side story and you know Mako's
will kind of tie into the plot just very
slowly and you sir feel like you're not
learning that much but it's not like the
Harry Potter movies always spent all
this time on one tiny detail that you'll
discover um where and then tensions
stories I mean okay a little character
development but I had nothing to do with
this story
oh yeah well that's another thing works
like we get all these promises like when
his daughter saw the statue yeah wow
what is this we still haven't gotten
back to that and I thought that was the
whole point of Tenzin being there was to
do that instead it became about training
lemurs and they're all cool side stories
but they're fun I'm like where what
happened with whatever with the statue
yeah the only thing really I mean I
would say bringing me back to this would
probably be just seeing the side
characters be themselves the story is
not really grabbing me in the main
characters not grabbing me
oh maybe that'll change now that they're
yeah maybe moving her yeah very
literally from the ground up she wakes
up III didn't want to bring up something
else
well what was your thought I'd you
finished first no I was pretty much
doubt I was gonna give away a spoiler
from gravity if I'm not going to oh yeah
okay um so I was asking last episode I
was like can somebody explain to me what
the republic's about cuz I didn't know
and the show a bunch of people a
materialistically or them folk
exhibitors oh yes
first off thanks for all the answers I
think it's cool I important tip though
feel free to read the comments first and
if 90 people have already answered they
don't need to answer because it was like
mostly people explaining the Republican
I think that it's the emotion of the
internet it's the I could tell her
before checking to see there's a noise
shakin any people is so the general
thrust I got was this was based off of
Aang's echo katara your original group
we're trying to figure out what to do
with all the colonists cuz you had fire
nation colonists and earth colonists and
the sanad and it was to give them a
place where they could all live together
in peace so it's a separate entity is
this like a spin-off of the promise
comic yes that's how that is the other
thing so and people just take what you
haven't read the comics no ashi i've
read the promise I've not read all of
them so they're just starting to talk
about like they haven't come up with the
solution yet by the end of the promise
and there's two more to go so but uh I
read them some easy well it was this
whole extra episode thing in the
beginning of season one a biker I got it
off of like Amazon I was watching it on
demand or something I must have missed
that cuz I don't remember that
explanation want to look or yeah was
there some sort of movies like well
there was a special episode or something
at the volume that I'll be very honest I
was in it to see blow up so
wholesome paying much attention to the
pot yeah nyah of I don't know they may
have explained it I have noticed that
like cuz i DVR'd this stuff I've watched
on demand I've watched via Amazon Prime
I they were actually differences in thus
it's the same thing with sleepy Hollow's
Sleepy Hollow will cut things about
backstory and stuff when you watch it on
demand versus DVR and awesome
I don't know what happened there maybe
they missed that so maybe that got
dropped from the version I saw but yeah
I don't remember that explanation but so
I've got the explanation now so it is
like a fifth nation as far as I can
gather you've got the the four earth
water you know all that and then there's
this fifth which is this sort of
collection of like colonists and stuff
and you know some of the point being yes
I was waiting for that
the point being so I was asking why
wouldn't the president get involved
because if it's kind of like the UN or
whatever isn't this in his jurisdiction
well thanks to you guys I know that the
answer is no it's totally not if he
wants to get involved he's literally
getting involved in someone else's war
and he has no real jurisdiction you're
just a vessel aren't freedom yeah it's
very jury it would be very Bush just
like I like what y'all doing here says
it just stopped us somewhere no I mean
it wouldn't stop us but is that is that
morally right so my only point is if as
much as going to the Mafia for yeah well
that's my point
yeah I mean that's my point so my point
is this
this makes Cora's an IRAs decision so
much crazier I mean so much
insane that it just blows my mind way
it's like okay so technically this isn't
a president being corrupt and saying
well it's not in our jurisdiction or
whatever even though it totally is this
is generally crowing cora trying to
start a war with another independent
nation and he was totally on board with
this totally just like oh yeah cora you
want to start a war i'm i'm totally fine
with this until the president themselves
just like yeah you would be branded a
traitor that's called insurrection LA
he's like oh sorry car I guess my hands
are tied
I can't start a war I mean bottom line
is someone's someone's being a major
insane douche and and that's it just
happens to be our supposedly like
chopped awake yeah and that's the thing
about the season is characters to me are
just making inexplicable decisions I
know people
mother and father's at stake this is
like I love my parents very much I would
have to think hard if I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna start a war over mom and like
oh they're not watching no I would I'm
like maybe I would do it but it wouldn't
be something that was like got it war
like I would be sitting there thinking
about this for a few days like huh well
and bottom line would well say this
before we wrap up here oh and then
you're right the Mafia thing like we're
just like what do we do let's go to the
Mafia I'm like we could trust the Mafia
what the hell but I mean the one thing
like you you're going on on about the
Republicans the Republic works what's
the presence to jurisdiction and stuff
like that I might was cured no no no
honestly it my thoughts the same thing
of like The Dark Knight Rises everyone's
like oh you're just focusing too much on
the plot points in the stuff that
doesn't make sense and at that point the
basis of here's the thing is that like
you know we can watch Star Wars or a
bunch of or India Jones a lot bizarre
stuff where there's a million things
like the x-men cartoon where half the
politics doesn't make any sense but the
focus and the enjoyment is so
entertaining and so gripping that you
don't question it as we think about so
wait a minute blah blah blah and you
know what who cares I'm loving it so
much I mean don't do that right you get
the Phantom Menace well I'm saying that
when you don't have the focus there you
are you do think more and more about
well way what are you think more about
the problems then you do what's good
about it you think more about what's
wrong about they doing and I don't good
about it and I again I think that just
has to be it's gotta be the main story
it's got to be the main character and it
just at least it sounds like we're gonna
try something different with a main
character thank God but you know let's
get the main story interesting to bring
in the spirits spirits that's what it's
called
that trailer I swear was like 90% spirit
I always seen them like in the the pilot
and occasionally like that I want to see
this spirit world and it's like it's
just a cocked in it she'll call
it you know let's go Cora
that's all it is you know what don't
Google that online
don't you a good image sir um I know I I
think the only thing is I mean you're
right you can pick up our plot point so
if you enjoyed that much but I don't
even give Star Wars a free pass some of
the things I don't like about like a new
hope are the same issues I have with car
I'm like Luke is kind of whiny and like
I like Luke much better when he starts
getting it together an empire and Jedi
and I mean in people talked about like
why did they cover up the hole in the
Death Star and while they destroy the
plant in front of them at that destroy
old you know whatever the rebel planet I
mean like little Donna I could write a
book about the plot holes but yeah it's
not that there's plot holes it's that
for the most part the character
motivations in Star Wars make sense
it's a few things that are kind of odd
you know but I don't like this one it's
when you have characters doing certain
sets of things and this is the problem a
lot of people have with the prequels
they're like well the characters in the
prequels seem really different from the
characters even the ones that are
supposed to be the same so I mean that
is an issue like and after the first
season I feel like I'm like are these
the same characters it's either like the
first season didn't happen or they all
woke up with amnesia or you know and the
plot points just don't make sense I'm
like this doesn't seem like the same
character from season one who is all
about you know bringing people together
doing this and that is that like I'm
gonna start a war or I'm a cop I'm gonna
go to the Mafia or it you know Mako's I
actually at least made a little more
sense to me because I think he suspects
those other cops are correct yes like I
may be but even then I didn't think it
was a very brilliant and we I'll say
this
we loved the well what we caught the
Alliance of comedians yeah where it's
like good guys bad guys have to come
together to go after a greater foe and
stuff like that but I think this is a
little different because it's very much
hey you're still gonna stay you know bad
guys is not like this is the only choice
I really feel like the choices they're
making are not the only choices
especially for peaceful people for
people are trying to do the whole focus
is to keep balance and peace well I'm
just going to the worst
yeah I was I think I turned to you and I
was like it just fascinates me how for
the way the first avatar show was all
about morals and ethics and trying to
find some in-between to maintain inner
harmony and peace this one is like drop
my morals at the drop of a head you got
it
and to get rid of the Fire Lord you know
you go to the Mafia I'm sure you know
just yet you have a drag accident slap
oh yeah I do ring that were you one day
that means it you know I won't just stop
with a giant bucket of water above his
doors spill on him but see they melt
what right like the witches in The
Wizard of no okay
give me that wasn't the best friend but
regardless you get our points oh yeah uh
we rebel down long enough I enjoy
looking up your Cora cactus take care